Tivoli Village is getting ready to
transform into a holiday Wonderland from
hot cocoa to Santa himself you will find
something for the entire family joining
us now is general manager Andrea blue
you got your red on yeah get ready for
holidays we are ready okay so I hear
there's new owners yes at Tivoli does
that mean we can expect some some new
energy for the holiday experience what's
going on well absolutely but with new
owners a new management team we're
excited to showcase our new holiday
Decor it's amazing so you really do have
to come out there and check it out in
addition to our holiday Decor we'll be
adding some events that will that we
amplify and get people into the holiday
spirit and we're talking about next
Wednesday because this is the big night
this is go time oh yeah look at this
next Wednesday is the tree lighting
ceremony and what else is happening next
Wednesday someone told me Santa Claus
will be there yeah so Santa will be
making her parents so next Wednesday
start at five o'clock we will be having
our our tree lighting event we'll be
having complimentary horse and carriage
rides hot cocoa and cocktail for
available for purchase at The Piazza by
Trixie mobile bars we'll also be having
giveaways we'll be having raffle prizes
to your favorite restaurants like Echo
and rig La Casa La Casa cigar bar and El
Dorado cantito oh there's so much to
enjoy at Tivoli and another gift you're
giving to the community small business
Saturday yeah so small business
Saturdays is a day that we really take
very seriously this is an opportunity
for us to highlight our small businesses
our distinctive retailers such as basari
Desert Valley
Gallery milk cow just a name
so we've got stretch lab we're a
Lifetouch lifestyle shopping center so
we have everything for lifestyle gifts
many opportunities restaurants I mean
you name it we have it so it's a great
opportunity for everyone to come out
shop with our retailers and provide you
know holiday gifts to their families and
you also have great entertainment as
well so Tiffany the Nativity Village
tree lighting is happening Wednesday
November 23rd complimentary horse and
carriage rides from 9 to 5 p.m 5 9 p.m
and the quartet carolers are going to be
appearing as well and here they are with
a preview
a five six seven
better
dude
[Music]
on Christmas Day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]